any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome everybody to this episode of the
nobel mines playlist
part of the arthur c clark center for
human imaginations
into the impossible podcast i'm your
host brian keating
and uh today's episode features uh carl
weinman who won the nobel prize
uh over a decade ago and this uh nobel
prize was
awarded for the discovery and properties
of strange
uh quantum materials called
bose-einstein concepts and their
applications and and bizarre properties
that they uh that they entail uh but
this podcast isn't about the
discovery uh for which he was awarded
the nobel prize
instead it's about uh pedagogy because
what carl's done is turned his
considerable attention towards improving
physics pedagogy
at stanford and elsewhere and this the
discussion that we have really was was
eye-opening but also
a delight for me to participate in
because
of carl's really wonderful way of
looking
at the obligations of an educator and
how this rule that you know is always
kicked around ten thousand hours role
that malcolm gladwell popularized
um and others have written about um that
this
uh that this world really doesn't
necessarily apply
as much as we think of them and and how
we can use
uh the actual pedagogical tools that
physics is uniquely
uh capable of of applying to better the
outcomes both for physicists but also
for society as a whole
we spoke about pedagogy in physics but
also
in aviation i mentioned him on skill in
training this was recorded a year or two
ago
and we're just getting around to putting
it
but we talked about my exploits into
getting a
certification to become a flight
instructor and
uh how unique an experience that has and
sort of the weightiness of
teaching people how to fly when they
could injure somebody else and perhaps
do damage
uh to themselves and other people and
maybe less directly impactful education
no pun intended
uh in the world of physics but where
there are commonalities
and how we can improve the outcomes by
improving the teachers
not just the students and we spoke a lot
about
uh you know his impression of current
university professors i'm not going to
name anyone in college but
he believes that you know the modern day
university professor is not that
far off from sort of bloodletting uh for
physicians in the 1800s and
leeches and phrenology so it's clear to
me that carl thinks incredibly deeply
about the biggest issues
of pedagogy takes us incredibly
seriously
and i love the way that he speaks about
as you'll hear
how you need to be well-rounded we
brought this example of
picasso being a role model to a long
dead role model
for students of art and his opinion on
how that can possibly translate
into understandings for improving our
outcome
as educators but even as lay people
interested
in in communicating the highest possible
topics
and we're all educators we're all
leaders and we talked a little bit about
leadership and what makes a good leader
in this episode as well so i hope you'll
enjoy it please
subscribe like comment review rate
whatever
it really helps us out and we're going
to have a lot more
noble minds on this podcast let me know
some
suggestions of who you'd like to see in
the comments below
thank you very much now enjoy this
episode
featuring nobel prizes
into the impossible podcast just for the
audio i always like to ask people
if you were uh somebody comes up to you
and says i've got good news for you and
bad news which do you want to hear first
the good news of the bad news
all right i'm asking you yes
[Music]
i'm not sure i have any questions no no
i'm saying if somebody tells you
i have good news for you and bad news
for you which do you want to hear first
you want to hear the bad news okay i've
kind of gotten 50 50. i had freeman
dyson on last
last month and he said he wants to hear
the good news because that'll uh
soften the below of any bad news that
would come later well i mean
probably this actually is is governed by
my work in education
oh really yeah where it turns out
negative feedback is much more useful
for learning
contributes much more to learning than
positive feedback right
right okay so you know to the extent
that you get
negative feedback you're going to get
the course card
actually so it just does dovetails
nicely into what i
uh the question i was dying to ask you
yesterday but you're uh
thronged by so many uh interesting
students i think that was the thing i
liked that the students were asking your
questions
about pedagogy um and your talk
yesterday about you know how do you
really
turn non-experts into experts uh so
i'm one of my hobbies in my copious
amounts of spare time is i'm working on
my
certified flight instructor rating so
i've got a commercial pilot's license
i've got all sorts of
experience but one thing my original
flight instructor told me 25 years ago
is
never stop learning because once you
stop learning you get complacent once
you get complacent bad things happen
and so i started uh this process of
getting my government issued faa issued
flight instructor
license and to do that you have to study
a great deal of human psychology and i
thought it was interesting i think it's
probably the only you know i can't
imagine the irs has
you know maslow's hierarchy of needs you
know that the
auditors need to know about or something
like that but it dawned on me that you
know i've been a professor for 14 years
uh and no one ever taught me how to
teach and
more than that nobody ever ever taught
me you know these basic principles
hierarchical
structure of needs whether you agree
with it or not i would be interested to
hear first of all your take on
is that a legitimate thing in the eyes
of you know in social sciences they seem
to
really cling to it and the fact that the
faa you know seems to want to prevent
people from dying
and so they feel like this is an
important thing you know the pyramid of
needs right in their handbook for flight
instructors
um alongside you know how to land an
airplane on
you know a single engine that only it's
a two engine airplane so what are your
thoughts on
on the kind of the classical modalities
of pedagogy
and as is there a reason that we should
or should not be teaching
physics instructors how to be professors
yeah they want
i mean it's
very clear now that yeah if you want
them to be good teachers
there's a there's a level of expertise
in that
in you know to be a good teacher
you have to have the kind of expertise
just like you do to be a flight
instructor
and that means that you have to know
about
the the research on basic learning and
connects with some
some basic cognitive psychology aspects
and you've got to know about how to
implement those things properly in the
classroom for the different ranges of
students you have
and you know 10 or 20 years ago
and certainly in the previous thousand
years which
universities are running what didn't
have that
research to show so you know it was kind
of
there wasn't anything clearly to learn
it was kind of individual art form
and the the trouble is we haven't
historically we haven't gone
past that yeah because we're just in
that transition region so i i
you know like that a pretty good analogy
is to think about medicine
so we're at the place medicine was in
about the
mid to late 1800s beaches and where
chronology yeah well yeah before then
you know it was kind of every crazy
idea that somebody came along and
declared themselves to be a doctor right
and you know that was all it took
and then but then you had this kind of
scientific medicine coming along
and and but you still had the people
practicing cookies you know their own
individual
idiosyncratic stuff at the time you had
real science saying no there's better
ways to do this so
my you know sound bite on this is that
you know the the
standard uranus dude professor is is
currently still practicing the
pedagogical equivalent of bloodline when
we there are antibiotics out there
right yeah it's a problem of education i
mean that's like the first university
was in you know eight 1088
and back then i always point out
although i don't do it to my students
when the students were unhappy with the
professors the students would go on
strike and the professors wouldn't get
paid
thankfully that barbaric process has
been replaced by tenure
nothing for uncharted to the students up
front that's right yeah yeah
we're charging for the wonderful
education to come
but uh but yeah i mean i feel like just
having learned a little bit and i never
encountered i've heard of that from my
social scientific friends but
but i never really encountered well you
know student needs to feel
you know say sense of security and
physical safety and all those things and
we can assume to for the most part a lot
of that's in place but then
you know a sense of purpose and meaning
and progress and and you touch upon this
in your talk
um but i you know what i took away from
your talk is this is this concept which
you know i believe is is attributed not
to malcolm gladwell though i think he
made it famous his ten thousand hour
rule which actually applies to pilots as
well i mean a master flight instructor
has ten thousand hours of flight time
i mean yeah i mean it's it's it's not an
accident i mean
yeah gladwell was really doing he was
talking about the work of anderson
anderson who's done all the
pioneering research in this and he
but he was playing a little fast i mean
a lot of it's actually
pretty close to the research but then he
wanders away
putting in his own stuff which the only
problem is he's not very good at
differentiating
right that's what's actually researched
and what's glad
that's right which so erickson has
actually just written a
popular book which you know you don't
have to read
well it's not reading between the lines
to correct a bunch of misconceptions
right
to undo the unring the bell the gladwell
yeah it's called
peak uh something about people all right
yeah your reference on your and your
title yes that's right so many people
but anyway i mean it's certainly ten
thousand
this arbitrary number ten thousand kind
of iffy but
certainly several thousand yeah
and i can certainly see that you know
just keep on you know beating this
metaphor to death but with that with
flight instruction
you know you you really can't encounter
the different weather systems and
altitude systems and air spaces around
big cities and small towns
unless you do accumulate a lot of hours
but in the in the
teaching of physics you know i remember
for myself i'm sorry
break and make a correction important
point there
you talk about you can't encounter all
those things but that makes a very
important point about those
those hours have to be spent doing the
right things
so if you went to always the same place
with the same website
you could do ten thousand dollars and
you're exactly an expert
some people say you know that applies to
all of these differences
exactly some people say you know you
can't you know you can get 100 hours of
flying experience you can fly the same
flight 100 times
uh you're absolutely right and in the
in and now it's kind of also dovetailed
with the statement that you mean you
also need feedback it's not just enough
to have
accumulation but i do feel like there
was an element you know at least in my
education
and i and i conversed with some of the
colleagues sitting around me yesterday
flight education oh sorry no physics
education yeah well whereas
you know when i i made it an analogy to
you know like the stephen jay cool you
know punctuated equilibrium where
you really kind of go from state to
state and a hopping mechanism like
when i learned what a fourier transform
is then i started to see everything in
terms of fourier transforms it wasn't
like
well i put in you know one hour's worth
of studying on trigonometry and then
another hour you know it was all of a
sudden now i could see things in a whole
new light and that opens up vast
different
areas so there there seems to be two
different evolutionary paths one where
you do
get big jumps and mental breakthroughs
and
you know but i think a lot of it has to
be done you know on your own
like as well as getting feedback i mean
the ratio is probably hard to determine
how much feedback
but and you made the good point that we
shouldn't waste our time you know
teaching
wrote stuff you know that they can
memorize or at least encounter before
class
but uh i wonder you know throughout that
i couldn't stop thinking about this
notion of creativity i mean whether
yeah okay so so i don't want to leave
creativity
yeah i've given a lot of thought to that
i do want to go back to your
great breakthrough yeah it's the latest
so so this is something congress
psychologists have studied apparently
and i wondered about myself but so what
their research has shown and they
and they get this actually best by
looking brain activity
okay and and what they see is that
it actually isn't the it isn't
truly uh you know struggle still go
sugar and then some great leap
uh what it is is it a struggle it's a
develop develop develop and then
suddenly it becomes apparent to you
but but your brain processing
has still been going on to to reach that
point
and you and it's suddenly you know you
it's kind of like
you suddenly opened the door but the the
the
stuff behind that door you were actually
had to have been thinking you know you
all that thinking
about was actually the prepping was
wiring the brain in the right
way okay you sort of completed the last
link linked to active work so so it
uh and you know i i think it's important
to keep
that that in mind because it it really
says no it's not
sort of oh i'll just wait around really
great
you know it really they come over there
your brain is actually or
yeah i see this in my kids too you know
see but you you see
i see sort of equal amounts of of linear
well they have to practice piano but
then all of a sudden they're
like wow they're really good at
arithmetic and
well they didn't spend extra time on
earth earlier it's just they they make
these cognitive kind of
and it would be great if we could tap
into that you know seven-year-old mind
every now and then
the connectivity but you just have to
realize it i mean and that sort of
supports the
the you know you get people you get
frustrated thinking i'm not really
making progress but right
you actually are and when you have a
great grade you should
you should recognize oh that's rewarding
all that effort
right right it's like see it's not
really that's not luck right exactly
right but that is a problem when
students are first learning when they
haven't had experience of really
learning something that's hard
and uh you know they've been given just
simple things to do
then they can very easily get
discouraged because they have no idea
you know kind of how the process works
they don't
see the perspective from them you know
once they've done it a few times but
anyway so that's an important thing to
deal with new college students
particularly once would
come from not very good high school
right and you know you made this point
yesterday that like you know there's
only there's probably some
saturation point as to how many
physicists a society like yours needs
you know but but of course you know our
job is education and
then the question that people have is
you know i mean i always heard
i think it's attributed to is it a rabbi
who said you know something like
you know if you're paid to do research
as a professor and if you're a gentleman
or gentle woman
you you also put some effort into
teaching and and then i you know i had i
had a conversation with my friends and i
was like well you know we're basically
like small business people those of us
that run labs we have payroll we have
travel we have a you know
account and then we have all the
supervision stuff we have committee
thing and then
and i'm like we're like ceos of a you
know very very very small fortune
one you know one million company and
then he said
yeah but they don't you know they don't
have tim cook teaching 40 hours a week
or whatever
and it's the question of prioritization
and i heard this morning just walking
i saw my colleagues down the hall
feverishly debating some of the points
you made yesterday
and it was just interesting to me
because you know as a parent now i have
five kids my wife and i have five kids
as a couple weeks ago
and we had twins and you know i think
about like
if i spend like an hour i'm learning
about parenting you know i feel like i'm
super dead or whatever my wife is super
mom but you know i think it's very
important that you give these talks
because
you know just spending an hour thinking
about these things that we really i mean
literally
never taught me how to teach and i don't
know if it's different at stanford or
elsewhere
but yeah and you know but i think it's
it's so important and and the way to get
it right it would be
great to kind of find a way to scale the
kind of i mean you've given your
presentation
elsewhere i know but and you have your
book about this this very topic
but um you know then the question comes
up you know what is our mission truly is
it to teach the undergraduates
is it to teach graduate students to
become us and then well are we just you
know
you know making you know clones of
ourselves and so that was
the question of creativity um you know
like as a physicist i mean a lot of what
we do and you asked this question of all
of us yesterday like
what are the core elements of what you
do and and how you characterize what you
do
and i had sitting next to me a
theoretical biophysicist i had a
particle physicist on the other side and
we were
you know we have very different thing
i'm an experimental cosmologist and we
have just very different toolkits
but the one thing that's hard and we
talk a lot about in the arthur c clarke
center premium imagination
is can you teach creativity and how do
you do it and i remember interviewing an
artist
who uh he was a playwright and an actor
and he played pablo picasso in one of
the plays that one man shows
unbelievable herbert seguenza is his
name
and he did a phenomenal job and i asked
him like well what did pablo picasso
think about the craft of
of of you know being an artist and then
how could you apply it to
being an actor and his thing was like
well papa kaz didn't start out with
cubism i mean he started off as a
classical artist and replicated the
masters
and i was thinking well i'm curious as
to what do you think i mean do you think
it would be
valuable to go over you talk about the
broiler i mean do you think there's a
value in the historical you know
teaching the the evidentiary you know
final
correct path of physics but basically
just repeating derivations or
i mean how is this notion of creativity
can you teach it i mean that's basically
my question
yes so so i i'm not going to
talk about creativity in the arts and
stuff yeah sure but i've thought a lot
about creativity
in science and i've talked with people
i'm talking about studies
and you know and i i can
this is one of the few places i claim
that nobel might be
some measure of
confidence in this area and
what i would argue is that
creative insights is it's pretty simple
it's basically where people are looking
at some situation or question about them
and simply
find a way of looking at different
than everybody else has been looking at
it
and realized that there's some other
information
approach which is the problem
medical calculation or new ways to
to understand how this describes you
know some physical phenomena that i
hadn't realized before
so it's really this idea of finding
a different way to look at it that's
i think in in every case i can think of
it it's not bringing in something
completely new it's bringing it's
realizing that
things that people already knew but
didn't really
didn't understand how could apply in
this situation
and so that means you sort of have to be
uh well grounded in the discipline like
picasso really had to know how to paint
right how to produce
images with paint and that in a real way
and you know i get emails almost daily
to
people who feel they're awfully creative
and not bound by all that
background nonsense of physicists and so
you know they can create infinite energy
they can explain everything
faster than like travel yeah and uh
whereas it's just nonsense and so
you know that's not creativity yeah so
uh yeah and you know in our in my own
work
i'll just give one example in both post
condensation really was very clearly
looking at this problem people tried
trying to solve this problem for
a long time and recognizing that the
bottleneck the real bottleneck they had
to solve
was not the bottleneck that they had
been working on
and and then if you recognize the real
bottleneck was all these
really cold atoms trying to get three of
them together to make a molecule
and that was the process you had to
suppress if you're gonna make them
things cool and dense enough okay and
that led to a completely different
experimental approach but
otherwise you're saying oh this problem
is more important than the other
problems
so but you had to have the wisdom too
it's not very brilliant but it was a
you needed to know about how atoms
behaved at really cold temperatures
and understand that all these troubles
they had originated from that process
and so so if you step back to think
about this from point of view of
education
what i would argue is the standard
educational approach we use
in science is it's not
ineffective in teaching creativity it's
anti-effect product teaching creativity
the reason i say that is that you know
if you think about really
in a normal course students don't learn
even a
whale taught course students learn all
these things and they're given these
tasks
they're graded on where the fundamental
measure
is always are you able to produce
the one answer that the instructor wants
to see exactly
and so that's that's completely the
opposite of being able to
think of ways to look at things or sell
problems that
nobody else has done that way and so
it's really squashing you know you're
penalized for creativity
up through every time start finishing
normal schooling that's right
i would say when people ask what's
graduate school like i say it's
definitely not like a harder version of
undergraduate because
in undergraduate you may not be able to
get the right answer in the homework but
somebody can you know somebody who's
able to get but
you might not even know the question and
you mentioned this yesterday there might
not even be a well-formed question let
alone an answer
and so how do you deal with that um that
discomfort that's after you've passed
all your graduates
before that no you have to get the one
right answer the call yeah the bane of
most guys
yeah exactly yeah you have to go through
this big hurdle that says no you can get
the
answer that all the parents want to see
you and that qualifies you and then
finally go out now and do things where
there isn't enough right what a stupid
system right
and of course for much of our education
we're we're always you know we're thrown
in with the
like medical doctors and you know the
one thing i don't want is my doctor to
you know take out the scalpels out and
just like really creative
you know so and it has a purpose but but
you know but the purpose as you say is
and it's probably anti-effective because
it was really set up i think ken
robinson or somebody made this point
that it was set up to train like
people to be useful in british industry
in the 1800s
and and that's even building upon the
bologna university model from a thousand
years before
and and so it's just it's just really
sad you know because i think
and and i know we're short on time and i
just want to finish up with i mean
there's always this notion
and you know i i i haven't seen that
it's more pronounced than my you know
dozens of nobel laureates whatever but i
have never seen somebody say well
you know i'm really really smart and and
you know here's here's here's proof
about my professor at a top university
whatever
um and so that means i can intuit all
these things that
you know are my social science or even
my english you know college
in the english department you know have
to take some training to learn how to do
or even
my kids high school teachers have to get
some training to know how to do
i think if we could crack that you know
it's kind of the is it bottom up or we
really focus on
the students and flipping the classrooms
and going workbooks and all those
wonderful things
those definitely work i've tried it one
way i've tried it the other way um but i
i feel like we need to make this
breakthrough of the educators we need to
they need to have a little bit more
humility even our colleagues in physics
that
just because you're brilliant i see this
with these projects
well i'm trying to be but it's the same
notion when i'm running an experiment
yeah you know and i've run i've worked
for people and i've run experiments
myself and
the notion is always well i'm super
smart and i could be doing anything i
want and and
you know i've chosen to be an
academician um but you know obviously
running a management and i'm like there
are books written by fortune 500 ceo you
know like on how to be a manager
and so why not like take advantage no
one i know does that we you know
no one's gone to business schools to
learn how to how do you run a
medium-sized corporation i think it's i
don't know do you think it's an ego
issue or
uh so you know i think it's no it's a
culture issue i mean first i don't
i know enough that people go to business
schools that that's not going to be the
right thing but there are certainly
things
that one can learn i mean i actually
read books on organization and
organizational innovation that were
really pretty useful both
of anyway oh research but also
in thinking about guiding changes and
teaching so there's
lots of you learned that there is
expertise there
but you know you also can't spend your
life going out learning things so
there's a real balance of efficiency
yes um but you know like
i i will say i mean i'll just point to
the teaching things where i've looked at
a lot
it doesn't take any more time to teach
well than it does to do
old traditional stuff and in fact
new faculty spend we've looked at this
they spend on their first teaching spent
enormous amounts of time
much of it ill spend yeah and so
you know and we find it takes a several
tens of hours for people to kind of
if they haven't been exposed to us to be
trained to be pretty effective and then
from then on it it doesn't take any more
time and that's huge
sometimes it takes less time and so if
it was
if there was the culture was just set up
recognizing
now there's some expertise you need to
make sure your new faculty have
and we're gonna set up you know training
programs to make sure that that's done
in a kind of most time efficient way for
everybody
if people at departments
start thought start thinking about let's
be more efficient let's take advantage
of the fact that
it's really not necessary for every new
faculty or every family member to
reinvent the course that's been taught
for the last 40 years
you know and spent all that time
preparing
uh and but that's so you know built into
the culture of it
but you made the point that until until
the faculties you know recognize that
they have to do it and have some metric
and maybe some carrot and stick right
some reward mechanism that's right and
just
yeah i mean right now there's
there's only a stick against doing it
and
so you know that's it that's a shift in
the culture so
that happens and i think actually people
will teach a lot better and they'll
spend less time on it yeah and i got no
problems with it
so that's great well fantastic thank you
so much i know you have a huge a very
packed schedule today thank you dr wyman
it's been great having you here at ucsd
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible
please subscribe comment share rate and
review
for a chance to win a free copy of our
most recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.gov
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division
of physical sciences at the university
of california san diego
eric vieri director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valco